-Our next guest
is an Emmy-nominated actor
you know from TV shows
such as Marvel's "Loki"
as well as HBO's
"Lovecraft Country."
He stars in
"The Harder They Fall,"
which is now streaming
on Netflix.
Let's take a look.
-You here for your
damsel in distress?
♪♪
-You don't look hard of hearing.
So I'm gonna ask you again.
Where's Ruby's book?
-Well, clearly...
you don't know me.
-Please welcome to the show
Jonathan Majors.
How are you Jonathan?
-[ Laughs ] Hey. What's up?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ooh.
-Now, I'm a little bummed
you're not here in person,
but I am hopeful that
I'll bump into you next week.
You're going to be here
in the city, in this building
hosting "SNL."
Are you excited?
-Am I excited?
Uh, hell yeah, man, I am. I am.
And when I see you,
we're going to do a tutorial.
And you're going to
do some tricks.
You're going to show me
some things.
-I'm going to show you
where all the bathrooms are,
and that's it.
-Okay.
-The rest -- It doesn't matter.
You have to learn the rest
on your own.
-Yeah, I'm looking
forward to it, man.
It's -- It's wild, man.
I feel like it's gonna be
drama school on steroids.
-I think that's a very good way
of looking at it.
And I actually heard something,
and I believe it started
for you in drama school --
that you keep hours
that might be very conducive
to the "SNL" schedule,
that you go to bed
at 10:00 p.m. at night
and wake up at 4:00 a.m.
Is this a thing
you actually still do?
-I do. I do.
As much as possible.
-I hate you.
[ Laughter ]
-It's tough.
-Yeah.
-But it's helpful. It's helpful.
And when it gets crazy,
night shoots,
you kind of just revert
back to drama school,
which is, like, class till 8:00,
and then you start rehearsals
at like 10:00 at night
and then work through the night
and then start back again
at 7:00 in the morning.
So it's like that.
Or you can go
to a newborn schedule,
which I don't know if you know.
That's also hell.
-Yeah.
-We'll be all right.
Then on top of that, jet lag.
So I'm looking forward to it.
-Yeah, that's right.
You are going to be jetlagged
'cause you're in London
right now.
You know, we just had Kumail
here from a Marvel movie.
You are working on the new
"Ant-Man and the Wasp" film.
And this is so nice.
You said you wanted to read off
like five or six spoilers
for us.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, so, first,
I want to say...
[ Mouthing words ]
-[ Laughs ] Oh, n-- Ohh!
I hate when Zoom cuts out!
[ Laughter ]
So you -- This Western
is an all-Black cast,
and it's a fictional story,
but you're playing real people.
-Yeah.
-Did you know anything
about Nat Love, the cowboy
you're playing in this film?
-I did not know much
about Nat Love.
However, I'm from Texas,
so I knew a lot about cowboys.
I knew a lot about the rodeo,
to a degree.
But not much about Nat Love.
He did write a book,
a 70-page autobiography,
which essentially just talked
about how cool he was.
And so I said,
"Okay, I got that."
Let me just apply that to this
script and take it from there.
But, no, I didn't know much
about him.
-Did you -- Coming from Texas
and spending some time
on a farm,
did you know your way
on a horse?
Were you comfortable
horseback riding in the film?
-I -- Yeah. I would say --
So, I did grow up on a farm.
I grew up also in Dallas --
Duncanville, Texas.
For those who know, you know.
But on this little farm
in Killeen, Texas.
And I would say --
Truth be told,
I probably know more
about roosters...
-Okay.
-...than I do about horses
when I started, you know,
doing the horse riding in films.
I had a run-in
with a rooster on a farm.
-Okay.
-It's pretty -- I don't want --
I have to break it down.
Because roosters. Okay.
So, on farms -- On my farm,
I would go out and get the eggs.
And there was a particular
rooster on a particular day
in which I walked in, and
this rooster was not about it.
I don't know if you know much
about roosters, but they're
quite territorial
and they're quite aggressive.
And unlike most animals,
roosters fight to the death.
-[ Laughter ]
-And so -- Yeah.
So, I go in to get the eggs
this one day,
and this particular rooster
on this particular day
was not happy
with this particular boy.
And so I go get the eggs,
and I come out.
And the rooster is --
I'm about 9 years old,
and this rooster is probably
the size of a Rottweiler,
to me, at the moment.
And he comes at me,
and me and this rooster stay in
this pen for about 12 minutes.
-[ Laughter ]
-And I leave.
Yeah. I leave with my shins
all tore up.
And I go into the house,
and I come back with a water
hose, just to make it even.
And me and this rooster
have it out some more.
And then my grandpa comes in
and grabs me and gets -- I g--
I get a butt-whupping all the
way from the pen to the house.
As I learned about roosters,
they're territorial and
they also don't like water.
Because if they get wet,
they can get sick.
And that was our livelihood.
So they're territorial,
and they don't like to bathe,
apparently, so...
-When you were getting
your butt-whupping,
was the rooster watching
and saying, "You've played
right into my hands"?
-I bet he was, yeah.
-[ Laughter ]
-You know, one of the cool
things about this film
is there's a great
musical element.
There's a lot of kind of songs
from the kind of performers you
wouldn't expect in a Western.
Jay-Z was a producer
on the film.
And you got to sing
a little yourself.
Was that one of the things
that drew you to it?
-I mean, that's one thing
about creatives, right?
I mean, you know this.
Like, you get us around each
other for a long enough time,
we're gonna try everything.
You know, so you got the horse
riding, you got the acting.
The music element was just --
just kind of came out of it,
you know, primarily because our
director, Jeymes Samuel, is --
I mean, he comes from --
he's Seal's brother.
He runs his own band.
But, no, I didn't know it was
going to happen right away...
but really leaned into it
when it came.
You know, with Jay,
you know, with Mr. Carter,
you knew it was
gonna be musical.
Had no idea it was
gonna be that musical.
You got Jay-Z, you got Kid Cudi,
Ceelo, Laura Mvula.
I mean, it's kind of crazy.
[ Chuckles ]
-It's an amazing film,
and you're great in it.
And I really can't wait
for you to be here next week.
Thanks so much for making time
for us. We really appreciate it.
-Oh, my pleasure, man.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Jonathan Majors, everybody.
"The Harder They Fall"
is streaming on Netflix now.
And next Saturday,
November 13th, don't miss "SNL"
with host Jonathan Majors
and musical guest Taylor Swift!